ah yes did Denver then went to Cheyenne
and uh did a trip from Denver to
Cheyenne and let me tell you something
we got a sprinter van and it was [ __ ]
dope because you can get the Sprinter
vans that all have the seats facing the
same way and then you can also get the
[ __ ] elevated version where the seats
are facing each other and you can have a
real conversation that jumps up the time
that you could have from nice from Goose
to silly goose dude this [ __ ] was
awesome when you're staring at each
other driving
dude it's like a by the way I didn't
know Cheyenne was an hour away from
Denver also Cheyenne where is it also
Cheyenne the capital of Wyoming also not
big enough to be a capital of anything
Cheyenne how many people do you have in
it 58 000 not enough how many people
were at the show one thousand that's
158th of the people knew that Chris
Delia was in town that's absolutely
insane dude I thought 1000 was a little
bit small of a show and then I realized
your boy 158th of the [ __ ] population
there it's moving up too low
played for Cheyenne and uh let me tell
you something dude
that's a black stripper name and it's
all good
right because it's the whitest place in
the world but it's a black stripper
named Cheyenne
unless you just felt like she's the one
that found it hey y'all we going we
gonna post up right here get your tents
out hey y'all look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] man
it's open if this place sure is open
[ __ ]
hey y'all get the chance bring them Yaks
over here
[ __ ]
look how open this is poster right here
that's gonna be Cheyenne I'm the mayor
[ __ ]
um
so yeah and then now there's 58 000
people there and it is a place I did not
know that Cheyenne was a place
where America the American government
can fire nukes anywhere in the world
in Cheyenne Wyoming
hey
also the reason is open space
if the bomb goes off only 58 000 people
die and you know that's a lot but it's
not you know it's not like you wouldn't
launch nukes from New York New York
Start Spreading the nukes
um
he wanna be a part of it nuke York nuke
York
so [ __ ] dumb
I Wanna Wake up in a city that's
permanently asleep
um
so yeah we did Cheyenne and Amanda the
ride the ride was so elevated in a in a
time you know in the not elevated it
wasn't actually physically elevated it
was so elevated the time was so elevated
because we were all looking at each
other and the tour report dude we were
doing all sorts of jokes the [ __ ]
driver on the Sprint Sprinter van we
would get too loud and he would [ __ ] put
up the partition dude that's the most
disrespectful [ __ ] you could do that's
so disrespectful to be having such a
good time and then all of a sudden you
notice that partition like the driver's
just like this [ __ ] God damn it and
clicks are partition and the partition
goes up and he can't see us
uh but we were having a good time and
then got to Cheyenne uh you know thank
you for coming out Cheyenne I didn't
realize it was an hour away from Denver
which means that if it was an hour away
from Denver what could have happened was
all the people from Cheyenne could have
went to the Denver show even though they
wouldn't have fit because it was almost
sold out but that's still you know
um
Cheyenne dude
Jeffree Star came out to see me uh which
was very cool
tall tall drink of water
um not sure the pronouns that Jeffrey
likes to use so I'll stay off it but uh
you know
have you on the makeup he looks good she
I don't know
um he he looks good and uh Google the
pronouns you know before I get canceled
again and um but uh good good good
person there had a good time was with uh
two two women that uh I've met before
through the merch company and um he was
great dude
it was awesome I was like did you guys
have fun I always I say that to people
because I have fun the two women were
like yeah and Jeffree Star goes like
this
um
and I was like playing it close to the
chest dude
now I'm insecure want them to like me
want everyone to like me sit deeper walk
in a room and I think that people don't
like me I gotta win them over
problem with childhood
why is it
this is who I am
been delving into therapy about it
walk in the room immediately think I
gotta win people over why
doesn't matter
every room
sad
but
my bag
uh everyone's got their bag of [ __ ]
isn't it
everyone got that bag of [ __ ] in it
um
and so met Jeffree Star and Jeffree Star
my cameraman was a big fan of Jeffree
Star he's like I get pictures like okay
he kind of looks like Jeffree Star to be
honest
um and uh
yeah man oh you know what happened in
Cheyenne I met a sheriff you know what
I'm saying like that actually happened
how hilarious is that
I bet you can't go to Cheyenne without
meeting a sheriff or somebody that used
to be a sheriff well I used to be a
sheriff down there
oh yeah yeah back in uh I used to be a
sheriff down in Provo Utah oh really
yeah what made you move up here ah man
you just got got a lot got a lot down
there didn't it so I need I need some
more space I need some thinking all that
shit's code for racism I'm all good uh
we love everybody equally even racists
um
[Music]
[Music]
you're crazy